[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks here we are we might be drunk
we're doing it and we got rum and cokes
here and our old pal
anthony devito man what's up what's
shaking good to see you dude nothing
much man good to see you guys oh you
went jersey tony on us in here you got
you're using the ottoman i don't think
anyone's ever used it before yeah man i
mean i i do like whenever i like to get
as comfortable as humanly possible in
any situation uh-huh because i i you
know i don't know you guys are pretty
similar where you like you have nerves
all the time do you know what i'm doing
yes yes like some kind of underbelly of
nerves so if i can get as
if appear as comfortable as possible my
body might be fooled into thinking like
i'm super relaxed right that's why we
put the whiskey in there yeah oh yeah no
man this is all great this is a great
setup i'm glad you guys could join me on
my podcast
it's great you know that that's that
[ __ ] is true though they say i read a
fun fact if you smile even if you're not
actually happy your brain will think
you're happy and it'll help you feel
better i think that's the movie the
joker right there
i'm doing great
yeah i must be that's how like dumb we
are that's so crazy that you could just
fool yourself with uh a smile but i
remember doing that like starting off i
think cause i saw like uh i think like i
would watch like nick turner seems so
comfortable on stage yeah and he would
just like he would hold the mic stand
and he would just kind of like lean in
certain ways
he probably was doing the same thing but
i was like that guy is comfortable so
for like for years i did that with like
but with like a timber like a shaking
voice you know what i mean i'm not
pulling anybody i totally this is gonna
sound like [ __ ] i remember you going
from here to here comedically with like
confidence yeah just kicked it up a
notch and i went up to you because we
were all struggling and you know you're
clueless as a comic should i do this
should i do that should i do this
and should i go blackface should i go
props you know
mark's case both yeah
we all supported it yes
thank you for that these were different
times
three years ago
hopefully that footage isn't unearthed
but
i hate unearthed it's so dramatic but
my point is yeah i went up to you
because i was just always looking for
tips or notes or anything and you i said
you your confidence is up what would you
do would you change and all you said was
every line that comes into my head i
just say it now
instead of worrying like is this funny
is that something is it you just just
regurgitate it all it doesn't work for
everybody by the way
i think mel gibson and michael richards
are the same thing
did not end well i mean there's a little
censoring yeah yeah for sure but no like
yeah but i think even i think i needed
that you know what i mean to then get
back to like okay i can think a little
bit more but i felt so reserved that i
was like oh i can't riff at all or be in
the moment because i'm so held back by
like whatever filter i have yes so it
was like i had to just be like oh just
say anything say it and then clean it up
later yeah and it was also that was
years ago where it was like before
everyone filmed anything anonymity was
nice yeah so it was like it was huge to
be able to just
bomb without any worry at all oh i know
isn't that crazy
i used to think about doing prom shows i
said the worst [ __ ] oh god oh my god
oh my god and then when you [ __ ] me
that was actually the least offensive
part
i was still doing my act
i still counted it
no i remember there was one night at lol
and it's like i can't remember for the
life of me what i said i just have this
very vivid memory of looking an old
indian man in the face giving him the
finger and going [ __ ] you and getting
off and it's like whatever like went up
to that moment like but it's like
exactly you're like yeah i am so in that
club he probably deserved it i still
stand by it i think he did i think it
was one rude engineer from bangladesh i
do but uh the good thing about you is
you can go wait i'm indian
you do have the ethnically ambiguous
look yeah what do you get
i mean i get i you know jewish is the
most common but i think that's just a
product of like living in new york
there's more jews here
yeah and others just means you're an
uncool italian yeah i never get italian
which is like always very insulting but
i i got this the other day and i didn't
really know what it meant because i
don't know a ton about judaism but i was
outside like joe's pizza like in
williamsburg and i was just seeing a
slice and this guy comes up to me and he
was like are you jewish and i was like
i'm not and he goes ah that's a shame we
needed a twelfth
yeah
jew i don't know for what what is that
like a 12-step jew program
i don't know but i for me i was like
you're not doing yourself any favors
with like their sorcery involved
it's like maybe it's a softball team it
could have been a softball team it could
have six on six softball i think it was
some and i don't know but i think it was
some kind of ceremony that
and not not anything devious but just
some kind of religious ceremony that
they look in the window they're putting
deer blood on their face
i think the jews do put uh like uh sheep
blood on the door it's on something it's
it's there's blood involved i'm a
terrible jew like orthodox like uh like
the super jewish do that yeah like
they'll use animal blood goats blood
yeah it is priests put it on their
finger after they do what they do
[Laughter]
that's just celebratory i don't knock
that
jew blood but yeah no i would get jewish
a lot i used to i mean like
i got mexican more when i was younger
but i think i've like aged out of
mexican a little bit and now it's i mean
now it's pretty much strictly the
occasional jewish but like the standard
is middle eastern yeah that's what i
mean yeah i see the most yes i get that
the most often like any audition i've
ever i've showed up to auditions i
remember showing up to an audition for
the part of samir and then when i signed
into the call sheet there were six guys
named samir there why
it was like yeah he's here like there's
no way i'm gonna get it that's crazy
it might not have been six there's
probably like three or whatever but
because he's good though for roles
because you probably the only guy who's
auditioned for harold and kumar
[Laughter]
yeah they save a buck that way
all right exactly yeah it i do and then
i have another uh memory of like um
whoever the guy is that directed the
bourne identities like doug i'm not sure
his last name oh lyman yeah doug limey
is a lyman yeah he's the first one he
did swingers oh okay yeah so he there
was something with like verizon
commercial and i would only go out for
like you know cab driver hot dog vendor
you know hijacker
so what is this verizon commercial and
they i was just doing the cab driving i
was doing the lines it was a call back
so it was like you know it's a big deal
it's one of the first auditions there's
so many people in the room i'm nervous
and like the more identity is like my
mom's favorite movie oh so i walk in and
i was like hey man poor identity is my
mom's favorite movie he could give a
[ __ ] about that yeah yeah so i sit down
i start doing the cab driver and they
just go they were like ah can you do
this like a little more ethnic for us
and i was like well like what do you
mean 20 years ago with this i mean this
was probably like six years ago yeah
this is pretty this limits change yes
you could get away with this in a
casting room so like and i was like now
they say a little more uh new york
authentic
right a little more i don't know jackson
heights
could you be smellier
so i [ __ ] so i'm doing it and then um
and i said because i was very i was like
i was worried because i was like look i
can't do the voice so if you want me to
do the voice it's going to be racist
right because i'm not good at the voice
and that's how it's just going to be and
they're like i'm sure it'll be fine
there we go yeah i i don't even say
words i just go oh dude
where should we go ma'am
it's not even in the script
and they were like yeah that'll be
enough
stuff i felt the character oh
you're the reason they killed off our
poo
yeah yeah yeah no and i remember hari
was right outside the room
and right after that i saw him take out
his notepad and just furiously right
but yeah i just it was exactly i was
like ah let me try to find it yeah so i
did that first to like wrap the engine
and it was so horrible you got down you
started praying
five times in the audience
and that's my biggest fear is that like
those casting directors get they have
the tapes and they just get drunk and
they just watch the tapes with each
other or they go oh this guy's somebody
now right we're gonna leave this
it's gonna be a tragedy but they get to
enjoy that later like remember that
[ __ ] guy with the booty i do kind of
love that yeah that they could at least
have a good time with that what is going
on with self tapes have you ever gotten
worse i've auditioned i've done 900 self
tapes i've never gotten one uh maybe
i've gotten two callbacks in 900 maybe
that's pretty good yeah we're not actors
no i mean that's the thing is like we're
going against people but think about
this we're going against people who
their whole life is acting right it's
literally like them showcasing on a
stand-up show with us yeah yeah like how
come i can't book this i know you're on
with pros and mine's like an iphone
tilted up on a counter and i'm like am i
in front of it you know and then you
have to re-watch it to make sure you got
halfway in it i'm always reading it with
my friend i read with john weisberg all
the time who's like stuttering through
his words yeah you're blowing the rhythm
i know yeah i do yeah i do with julia my
fiance who's like gets too into it there
gets like it clicks in her a little bit
that she's like i could have this role
right and then all of a sudden it's like
you're making this about you and now
it's a major problem because you're
doing so much better than me off screen
right like you're making me look
horrible right and i get it yeah i also
think i mean the three of us
not that whatever you guys you know like
you guys are amazing comics but i don't
think the three of us whatever shut up
but keep it moving um
but the three of us i don't know that
we're like natural performers no you
know what i mean
we love writing jokes and we love stand
up but like
you know if i if that just happens to be
the medium we have to we have to get up
there and say the jokes yes you know
acting is i mean look some great comics
are great actors of course but a lot of
acting is the opposite of comedy comedy
is like trashing pretentious
vulnerability yeah all that [ __ ] and
that's our whole
that's our weakness i see head shots and
i'm like you know yeah
that's actors yeah exactly there's
something too to be a good actor you
have to be able to read bad dialogue
well and yeah and like we hate bad
dialogues yeah we're more writers and
actors so it's you know and you have to
like turn that part of your brain off
that's like insecure and some of that
insecurity makes you a great comic
because you're constantly in turmoil
with yourself right inside so if you're
an actor you just don't hear any of that
and you can just be so emotional and
vulnerable yeah but every moment we're
checking ourselves and being like you
can't what are you nuts you can't act
like that you lunatic oh dude but that's
what makes you great as a comic terrible
as an actor exactly that i did an
audition in la and i went to the place
this is
eight years ago i was damn remember
going to auditions oh it would take your
whole day you drive around la in a
rental car it's eight hours between you
gotta go to malibu you gotta go to santa
monica then you gotta go to venice it
was a nightmare so i had three auditions
and it took the whole day so i'm in this
little bungalow trailer thing on some
lot and they're like okay did you get
the sides i'm like i didn't get the
sides even though i got them and i never
read them so i was like i'll wing it
i'll figure it out when i'm there i get
there they go okay and i sat down with
an old man and they gave me the paper
and it's i read it real quick
he dies next to me my dad has a heart
attack we're watching a football game
and
they get the dad's like
and i'm like
dad get out of here what are you crazy
ah and they're like get out get out they
kicked me out that's how bad my audition
was i drove all the way there until like
an hour
ten seconds i was gone that's that is
that's so funny i can't act like yeah
it's sadness right you want to go i just
met this guy yeah you break immediately
and you just be like i just want to be a
real person in front of you
the situation is hilarious so mark
having to show emotion oh
i couldn't do it i couldn't do it yeah i
would i would well let's try it real
quick mark i'm dying right now
this is your friend sam dynasty let's
see if you can do this this is an acting
exercise for mark ready
all right what are you gay
come on get it together
but no one's tried that maybe it brings
the guy back to life nobody knows
he's not wrong
science isn't there what are you choking
on stephen
shut up you prick all of a sudden you're
revived
mark you're reading for a civil rights
lawyer marco said ah yeah [ __ ] queef
[ __ ] you you queef
that's not even the size
we don't know what you're doing
yeah i would love i would love to have
seen i think both of you for different
reasons like in an audition mark for
that reason and sam for
some sort of confrontation that you
would find somewhere in there yeah just
with somebody who who you call a phony
well
i could do that one i think yeah
i had a uh
call with my
my what do you call it the guy the guy
who finds you gigs like the audition guy
oh sure the acting acting agent
yeah one of those guys this guy dean
really cool guy slick la guy yeah and he
was like
so i want you to know like if you have
if you don't feel you know connected
with a role like if you read it and it
doesn't hit home for you you don't have
to do it because i was just doing
everything just trying to be nice
totally and i was like oh i didn't know
we could he's like yeah no we want you
to just go out for rolls you want i was
like okay and he should have never told
me that because now every email i'm like
not connecting not connecting
them anymore not connecting not
connecting this one says comedian with a
drinking problem like yeah it's not
working
i can't do it i got no rain
these asians sometimes like they they're
like you could do this i'm like you're a
better actor than i am yeah right oh
that's a really good point you're
believing in me totally so true been
acting the whole time you signed me
every email everything how are you not
doing housing for you it's your age and
you're killing it yeah you're killing it
i'm like you're you're good yeah yeah
you're good the amount of times they've
said you're killing an atom
you have the best can we tell that asian
story oh sure yeah this is one of my
this is one of the best i mean did i
tell you this oh yeah great man this is
like um so this is i guess this happened
like sometime last year right so i write
this script you know um it's getting
good feedback from a lot of people i'm
like really excited about it so i sent
it out people are responding like right
away i sent it to my agent he doesn't
respond for a month and like it's so
crazy how we're so ingrained that we're
like that's
kind of standard but it's like that's
nonsense you know what i mean like this
is your one job i gave you a thing
that's good this is your job to sell
that thing you should be so excited so
he doesn't get back to me and he's like
finally does get back to me and like his
response was it was so condescending he
was just like scripts are hard but you
wrote one and that's great
not even like that's like subtext that's
like pretty much the email holy [ __ ] i'm
furious i want to tell him to [ __ ] off
right back so instead of that like my
writing partner i mean you guys know
shaqi so he's writing it with me yeah so
he's like don't email your agent that
just you know let off steam email that's
your manager so i'm like so i email that
to my manager but i'm also in the email
like making fun of him for like you know
like it's like agent agent speak where
they're just like i'm so jiminy jazzed
about like what we're working on these
days my man right so like i email my
manager back in the way he talks and
then he email him back in the way he
talks so i'm like man i'm so super
psyched to have you on the project like
tell me the lot you want in malibu let's
look at real estate right now let's get
on zillow like that kind of attitude
yeah so i send that to him but not
knowing that i copied and pasted by
accident all the [ __ ] talking i was
doing to him in the body of that email
so i sent him everything
what kind of [ __ ] are we talking like
[ __ ] this guy or i hate this guy a
little bit of that but like more like
impersonating him
in emails which is like i would say even
worse yeah do you think he caught it
yeah he read it all of course he read it
all so he emails me back he almost be
back and he goes like hey that's great
news like about like this network
responding to the project but uh i don't
think you meant to send me all that
other stuff that you sent in the email
oh and uh yeah i was like you know look
i'm so like i'm not like i'm sorry you
have to like read that way yeah but i'm
not sorry about like any of the like uh
any of the actual feelings like sure but
uh damn that's brutal yeah i know it was
i i felt it was weird because like i
felt at some point like i was like yeah
it's funny so i it was just like it's
like a fun story and i did feel kind of
like all right this had been going on
too long and i probably would have just
let it go on forever yeah so it was kind
of like a way out of it but i did feel
horrible that that's the way he found
out you know what i mean like i even
like the lowest person in my head i
never want them to be in that position
no matter how much they've wronged me
like that i was like that's [ __ ] up
yeah but yeah i had a similar thing
happen with an ex-girlfriend i texted a
friend like i would come by but i gotta
hang out with my dumb girlfriend it's
gonna be boring as [ __ ] and i sent it to
her
and but luckily it was so mean that she
thought it was a joke sure yeah so i was
like thank god i was mean you have to
like ham it up even more the next three
she's like this seems pointed
dumb [ __ ] i hate her so much what does
my mother have to do with this yeah
but i got away with it thank god but boy
the feelings you go through of like how
can i reverse this can i go back and do
a superman and spin the earth back like
you want to like you're praying to god
for some kind of
yeah rewind button i felt that for a
second but i think if he was like a
better agent i would have actually felt
that but i think i was more like hey i'm
like kind of happy he like
knows that i'm pissed off yeah i'm not
happy that that's how he found out but i
am happy you worked hard in the script
and it's like you want at like fake
support or something not yeah yeah what
about uh
can you talk about the show you're doing
now the one man show yeah of course yeah
ask me you know anything you want about
that yeah so i started doing that great
premise it's exciting as hell this yeah
i'm excited too man it's been like it's
been interesting and completely
different to do because like you know
we're all like comics that came up in
new york so you're like one you're like
so many jokes per second you know that's
how we came up surviving at open mics
that way sort of like to do so i'm doing
this one-man show about my dad who was a
maid man in a crime family and i found
that out when i was 18. up until that
point my mom told me that he just died
in a car accident
so wow yeah so at 18 i found that out
and then like
10 or like you know about 10 years after
that i found out that like he had been
in prison for like five years he was
like
you know like a murderer like he was
like a contract killer he was a violent
hitman italian guy from jersey
all right what are the odds yes jack
holy [ __ ]
yeah did he have a cool nickname uh he
actually didn't have a cool nickname
which i was a little dizzy yeah
but then i was like i was you know i was
a little disappointed but i was also
like all right that's kind of good that
he's not like you know that's my father
knuckles malone yeah
i mean like it's still my dad so i was
like it was kind of a measured subdued
like nickname right right you got the
same eyes as the ice pick
yeah
a contract killer that's crazy man yeah
it's pretty it's pretty heavy i mean
obviously there's a lot more to him as a
person than that but those you know
those are the things i read in a
newspaper wow so it was yeah it was
pretty heavy to find out so i yeah so i
started like i wanted to because i never
really really talked about this with
anybody like my mom was like don't ever
talk about this anyway when i was 18
years old like even friends whatever but
your safety yeah for my safety a little
bit of like
she went through it all with him so like
for her like she knew
i guess like the um the stakes of like
what he was and what could happen and
what could be but i mean this is years
removed from it but i also understand
her concern of course so i never said
anything but then years went by and it's
like man you hold on to something like
that especially around like you know
it's like i didn't tell you guys until
recently right i know your dad died of
cancer yeah exactly it's like yeah i
don't like lying like i don't like lying
in general you know what i mean unless
it's like very fun and i'm at a wedding
but like
i'm a doctor
yeah but like you know i i hate keeping
anything from the people that you know i
love in my life so i was like yeah it
was like really hard for me to do so
eventually i was like i don't want to do
that any longer and especially like
comedy in new york it's like truth is
currency you know it's like i just
didn't want i didn't want to do that any
longer so made that decision and then
was like okay i'll start talking about
him on stage just kind of thought this
would be a chunk in my act and then as i
was doing it i was like yeah the jokes
weren't hitting and i don't like you
know maybe they weren't great jokes but
also it was like i think people in the
audience were like this is too
complicated to just like unpack
upset i have a similar problem yeah it's
tough right you have one of my favorite
lines that i think about all the time
about how you know when something crazy
happens to you like let's say you get
held up at gunpoint or whatever and
people are like oh that's going to be a
killer 10 minutes the pressure to write
that is so strong i can't think of it
because i can but i could write 20
minutes on like gay sex of course you
know because it's just there yeah and
you have that joke he's or that line
about like my mom is dating a black
blind right
whatever it is yeah and i've never felt
more pressure to write a joke yeah so
you got a punch line about that problem
i'm so jealous of that line oh it's a
very good exact comedy joke yeah yeah
yeah yeah that was one like that
specifically because people where i
would tell them that story they'd be
like you gotta write about this but
everything i had was like it just felt
cosmetic and i wasn't getting to like
the core of what it was and i think yeah
cause i think you do a similar thing
where you like you record and then
listen to like what you're like with
jokes you're working on and everything
that i've like heard wasn't hitting and
then that was the line where i was like
oh this is the only thing that i think
like makes sense for the situation so i
was like even if it's more comics that
get it this is like to the bone where
other stuff felt more on the surface
right so yeah so with this show that's
what it felt like where i was like oh i
can't just unpack this in like five
minutes at the end of a set like this
needs to be so it's nothing it's not
like
the type of it's too complicated yeah
and and real yeah i mean people are like
you're following someone going you know
dating's weird
my dad was murdered and they're just
like all right yeah are you on tinder
though
you don't understand
yeah dad on tinder
[Laughter]
are you cool
dad cool well it's such a it's such a
it's funny like rock will do a thing
chris rock will do a thing sometimes
where he repeats a premise
[Laughter]
yes you know and
i mean yeah this is a this is a rich
topic for
clubs
yes it's um yeah and even going back to
the rock i think that's why he's like my
favorite and such a master because he
had like hit such heady smart ideas that
he was like saying he was performing to
audiences that normally wouldn't get
those right he had to like
he performs the [ __ ] out of those in
such a way that's probably unnatural to
him but he's smart enough to know like
well if i want to get across what i want
to get across it has to be done this way
yes it's just such an accomplishment as
like a writer writer-to-performer kind
of thing i know it's so hard it's so
hard to write heavy [ __ ] and make it
accessible yeah and quick and packaged
to where it's funny yeah and they can
just eat it up and maintain your
integrity with the idea like it's so
it's so difficult yeah but yeah to what
you're saying yes like um
that that part of it uh
that i've never done this before because
like i'm more of a joke guy than a story
guy but with this like it
i was doing it as like more like in the
vein of like a series of stand-up jokes
while trying to like tell the story and
it just like it wasn't working because
of the personal nature of the story and
it's a lot of stuff that like i've never
really talked about before and
especially on stage so like i'm working
through it and i always thought like
when people said that in like such a
like a esoteric-y kind of way like i was
like yeah that's kind of [ __ ] but
then like as i'm doing it like i am
feeling that where i'm like some of the
lines like i'll say and for a brief
second i'm not remembering them i'm
saying them
and i'm like [ __ ] this is like hitting
me in the moment and like i'm about to
cry and i this is [ __ ] up have you
talked about this stuff in therapy
before performing yes yeah oh the minute
i plopped down in therapy because i
couldn't talk about this with anybody so
she was like she was like hi so you're
anthony i was like my dad was a maid man
and she was like let me get my pen
she's like this isn't going to analyze
this situation
they did that
that to me is so interesting because
you're trying to work through it as a
human but then you're also yes you're
like was that funny that line i just
gave you oh yeah yes
your dad's thinking my son's a [ __ ]
snitch
[Laughter]
yeah that is the interesting thing
because it is like it is very heavy
complicated material but i know that i'm
still doing a show yeah so it is like
there are like there are lines and
especially too because some of the lines
are just like they're serious because
i'm trying to i'm trying to convey
emotion that's not just laughter only
because the moment needs that like i
wouldn't if it didn't i wouldn't but
there's like i've never wrote that way
so like you're running the line of likes
being saccharine and that's been the
challenging part you know what i mean
like saying a line that's like effective
emotionally but doesn't seem like i'm
purposely trying to be effective yes and
then yeah you have those like i'm like i
don't know if that tag works about like
him being in the trunk you know what i
mean it's like it's insane just sort of
like split your brain into these
different places and still be like a
human being that's crazy but this is
great because these one-man shows are
one-person shows a lot of them i feel
like they're trying to replicate that
yes feeling part and you're a good comic
so you have their feelings are real and
you get the great writing so this i
can't wait to see it yeah man i mean
it's it's get it's getting there it's
just a matter of like uh it it honestly
i i didn't i never i don't i still don't
know if it's a one-man show i don't even
know what that is i just know that it
has sad parts so i'm just saying that so
people aren't like disappointed that
it's not a full stand-up hour sure sure
but like that's good that's okay it
feels like a more theater show yeah
broken it down yeah one man
yes the pace of it because i approached
it just with like let me just fill it
with jokes not and this is a lot to shaq
his credit who's also directing it who
was like really great at being like no
like this needs to have an arc you need
to have like a reason that you're doing
this like he put all the pieces in place
that's like this needs to we kind of
like we kind of needed to approach this
more of like you're writing a pilot than
you are writing like a stand-up app oh
wow so like it needs you need to like
establish a character in the beginning
of like this is who you are this is why
this problem in your life is so
difficult and these are the stakes of
that problem right and then it goes from
there like a neil brennan kind of thing
yes yeah he's doing a similar piece like
that thing i think it's called
unacceptable right it's all about his
childhood and all that but it's it's an
hour but it's more yes
what uh how is your mom dealing with you
doing this i mean she
uh so i mean it's interesting because
she always looked at my dad because she
knows my dad as like not just whatever
you would read in the paper you know
what i mean like and like the sopranos
does this a wonderful job of depicting
like people in this life all sides of
them so like she knows him as this guy
who loves to dance and who loves to like
go to broadway and like these sorts of
things so she saw him as like someone
who it's like if he wasn't
kind of born into this if he was just
given a choice he might not have done
this in what ways was he born into it i
mean like i mean it is you're born into
it yeah
like you're you know if you grow up
around it or raised in it you're gonna
be um you're gonna be more susceptible
to falling in line was his dad uh yes
yeah so like
his like the surrounding element to him
was all in it so it's like you know even
if like you know people want to say like
you always have a choice but it's like
you kind of don't if it's just that's
completely your environment so my mom
for him
she was like oh i know him as this other
version so for me if she stopped me from
doing a thing that i wanted to do to
express myself she would be doing to me
what was done to him okay so and that
way she didn't wanna she kind of didn't
wanna i guess make in her head that same
mistake so for her she was like i can't
stop you from doing this but she does
everything is run by her um wow
does she laugh at it yeah she thinks i
mean she contributes and that's why i'll
say that's the hardest part i mean it's
kind of i talk about in the show a
little bit but like yeah i have to like
my mom pitches me jokes for the show and
i have to be like yeah man we can't do
that you gotta put it a small dick
she literally said stuff like that my
mom is constantly trying to work in the
movie ocean's 11. like it's very
difficult to turn these things down wait
can i ask a million i got a million
miles yeah man just ask whatever you
want all right so you grew up you didn't
know he's in the mob until you went to
18 you said okay
so would you guys must have been pretty
well off i mean he's a made guy he must
been bringing in big change no i mean
he's also a gambler so a lot of that
goes like out the window a little bit
okay um so no no my i mean my family
it's my house is my mom my great grandma
my grandma and my youngest daughter
whole it was like yeah it was like those
people who lived in a shoe
yeah a lot of estrogen a lot of estrogen
wow
did he hate you not hate you but was he
like my son's a puss no i mean like he
was i mean he was dead when i was born
oh so i didn't know yeah no it's okay he
died when i was born so i would have no
idea but
for what my mom has said of him he was
like kind of like a song and dance kind
of guy oh and he loved they would go to
danger fields like all the time really
yes cause like dangerfield's back then
was like the spot it hasn't you know now
it's gone but it hadn't really changed
since yeah right but like so they would
go to dangerfields he loved comedy wow
so there is that thing of like oh i
don't think i think he he would be proud
i mean if anything like he would it
would be awkward yeah he's in the crowd
right there's like a gun on a table
but um but yeah so i you know i don't
know but i do think like he would be
proud of me in that aspect and like it's
like man if you're in that and like
like real tough guys don't need to be
tough all the time oh yeah you know what
i mean you just kind of it's there when
you need it and that's what really
separates you you don't have to tell us
dude yeah no who am i talking to it's
like a fight club in here this is like a
ufc locker room
[Laughter]
but like you know like so many people
that posture so much it's like well
they're not gonna do anything yeah like
the people i mean this isn't true all
the time but the people that are like oh
i know i have this in me and i'll just
let it out when i have to like it's like
those are the people you generally have
to worry about right and like from what
my mom describes he was of that ilk so
like i don't think he would be like my
son's a [ __ ] as much as like he would
be like oh yeah he doesn't when he
doesn't need to but if something
happened maybe he would you know um did
he have a temper yes oh boy yeah that's
exciting yeah no and i i have a temper
yeah yeah so there are qualities like
and like knowing that two is interesting
and i think that's you save a temper but
you're pretty you're a pretty calm guy
though i'm pretty calm but if i flip
it's like
it's like embarrassing do you know what
i mean like where you're like because
i'm not i'm not used to anger so like
when it happens it's like it's i'm like
a new person at it do you feel like you
bottle a lot of it up maybe to i think i
do i mean like i like i was we were
talking yesterday i was like i have a
night guard so i must you know what i
mean like oh something is happening
yeah cause i grind my teeth it's a big
italian guy outside the department
they call him vinnie nightcard
do you need dental work
so you have a lot of anxiety uh yeah i
do but like um
yeah he was more my mom would say he
would get a look in his eyes and when he
got that look in his eyes that's when
you were like you got to get away from
him because yeah cause after that it's
like it's red after that and like
growing up i i mean i'm i'm you know
luckily for me i didn't grow past like
five foot six right like i think if i
was
bigger i might have had more of the
quality that i had when i was younger
which is like yes i was very quick to
snap and if i did it was like you know
red like i fought a kid for a whole year
when we were in third grade like you
know they would lock us they would lock
us in the code room and shut the lights
and i would just go at this kid who was
like way bigger than me really cause
like i do have this streak in me and i
think that's why i am very tempered as
well because i know it's there but i
also know my like demeanor and i know
that if like if i have this like sort of
like killer be killed mentality at my
size i'll be killed so i think it's also
like i'm very aware also of like just my
size yeah
um gotta we think we've got your
nickname and anthony the third grader
[Laughter]
we might be drunk is thrilled to welcome
our new sponsor fanimal
i love live events i hate buying tickets
the hidden fees suck and coordinating
with your friends is the nightmare
they're garbage i always end up fronting
a bunch of money and chasing down my
friends to get reimbursed not me
personally because i'm very generous but
if they flake i'm stuck with a whole
bill and then i discovered fandible
fanable has tickets to everything
there's no fees the price you see is the
price you pay that's i mean that's
pretty big yeah not only those prices
transparent but they're almost always
lower than anywhere else i look and for
any hot ticket like coachella a laker
game or dave chappelle fanimal is always
the cheapest option nobody gives nobody
goes to live events anymore so why buy
tickets alone fanimal although if you do
come to a show alone there's nothing
wrong with that honestly i love that
someone tweeted me about that the other
day they're like i wanna is it weird my
friend's bail is it weird if i come
alone i said no dude enjoy yourself yeah
and you know what the guy made new
friends at the show they tweeted me
afterwards i sat with these guys and
they were tweeting me too so you end up
having a great time no matter what
um animals patent group purchase makes
it easy first you set a minimum size for
your group and you choose the number of
tickets you want to pay for yourself
then you invite friends when the minimum
size is met everyone gets charged and
receives their ticket if the minimum
size isn't reached in time nobody gets
charged you don't commit until your
friends you march tell them how mark i
called you march
march march normand tell them how to do
it oh yeah and family has amazing
customer service don't take my word for
it check out their hundreds of five star
reviews the next time you need tickets
go to fanimal.com and sign up with
code drunk
for 20
of credit
20 of credit towards your first purchase
we drink on this show check out fanimel
and experience more support the show and
get twenty dollars off your first
purchase with the code drunk at
fanimal.com f-a-n-i-m-a-l
dot com get on hey
we might be drunk is brought to you by
lucy you're a responsible consumer and
you want a responsible way to consume
your nicotine don't you
well if you're looking for nicotine gum
lozenges or pouches to use nicotine to
relax focus or just unwind after a long
day there's only one stop you should
make
lucy
i like this stuff the gum tastes great i
prefer the lozenges because you just
throw them in you're not smacking around
town with the chewing so uh get on it
plus you know
it just tastes good and it gives you a
little jolt that yeah oh yeah it gives
you a kick if if i'm hungover
i pop one of those in and i'm like
pretty good it's at least healthy
endorsement of all time also if you're
going to the casino you're hitting the
slots just chew the gum and you get the
same the nicotine without having to kill
your lungs
so you've been looking for an
alternative to smoking why not switch a
nicotine product that can actually make
you feel good and feel good about doing
it tell them how fatty if you enjoy
using nicotine you should definitely
check out lucy's products at lucy.co
that's lucy.co promo code drunk at
checkout also i have to read this
disclaimer warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical remember if you're interested
in a better way to use nicotine visit
lucy.co and be sure to use that promo
code drunk
here here
was there ever any temptation for that
type of life for you was ever a point
where you're like well maybe you know
maybe i am my dad's kid you know no i
mean i think like after the fact i would
think that if i ever got to that point
where i was like really mad um and like
i couldn't see out of my uh
anger
but like otherwise no cause that's too
far gone you know what i mean like my
mom did do a great job of like keeping
me so far away from it until having to
tell me at 18. like it's like i wasn't
allowed to watch the godfather growing
up like i didn't see that so i was like
30.
wow because she was
because that story is basically about a
guy who's outside of things and then
gets pulled into business and then
becomes and he's like this like scenario
yeah exactly
yeah no man it took me until like a
couple years ago until like i watched
the sopranos because it's like i mean
they shot the last scene in my hometown
so it's like it's very
real in some ways and and real
i mean real earth for my mom because she
went through it realer to me just
because it's like the attachment is
different like when i see tony soprano
i see my father and i can't not separate
that and like in the lowest moments you
go oh this is hilarious they're burying
a body in the woods these are characters
yeah but i go that's my [ __ ] dad damn
so it's like
so it's always been like heavier for me
and it's not to say i don't love the
show and i think the show is like done
this amazing job with nuance with like
these lives um but like that's part of
the show is being like hey like i'm not
saying you're wrong for thinking all
this stuff is cool i just can't agree
with you until you know everything about
me that's really it all said you're here
that's interesting yeah and and it would
be weird if you could just separate that
totally it'd be nuts if i was like isn't
it hilarious like it's like that would
be crazy if i was that dispatched do you
know and this is a little little squeefy
here but do you know how he died
yeah i mean he was yeah is that giving
away too much no trevor is that what
this is queefy
you're not exactly on fresh
air little
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't know this is too
provocative i don't know yeah personal
there you go personal is good all right
personal i like it i like spicy
sam the book reader
has made it personal um no it's not at
all no he was um yeah he was found in
the in the trunk in uh manhattan whoa
well he made it to the big city yeah at
least yeah but
damn that he's fine man so uh on the
nose you know it's so mob yeah yeah i am
yeah i know that um
yeah
exactly and it's it is pretty funny
because like people sometimes people
just guess it and then i just have to
say yes do you know anything right right
like was he found in the trunk and i'm
like how did you know
it's very awkward i mean that's horrible
for your mother i i can't imagine like
you know
were they on good or bad terms when this
happened they were i mean they had just
had me seven months ago but damn and he
did five years in prison he did five
years in prison but he said he said a
thing
going into prison which kind of
made like my mom every time you know
ever you know you you know you get these
little hints along the way of like the
severity of what he's doing but my mom
like i said she knew him as this like
very loving and warm person and he was
you know
but um he before he went to prison he
was like if you cheat on me while you're
in there i will i'll kill one of your
sisters
so it was like that was the moment where
she was i've had women say that to me
though yeah that's that's right
i've i've seen this at the fap
[Laughter]
but like that was a moment for her when
she was like
oh i have to give up you know what i
mean i have to give up on him so at that
point i mean they weren't on
good terms but it was still like hey man
this is her husband and when you have a
child you know things do like that
clouds you a little bit sure so i'm sure
she was like it probably was like a lot
of ambivalence and then but like when
this happens it's so gruesome and
horrific that it's like no matter what
you hearken back to the moments when you
like knew this person as like alive and
bubbly and joyful and warm and all these
other things so it's like yeah it's like
i mean so that the show really her story
drives the show like that's
like not to get too technical but it's
like that's the a plot and then the b
plot are the parallels in my life which
feed into her story right with like
running themes behind it but like really
the show is about her like i purposely
don't say his name i mean i don't say
his name in the show for like obvious
reasons but i don't say his name because
it's like i want people to take away
that like this is this is my story about
my relationship with my father and who
he was obviously that's why people are
there but at the end of the day like
this is her story and like the strengths
she showed and everything that like she
went through well she protected you from
that yes from that life yeah yeah she
she and this is one of her lines she
said when uh he died it was a chance for
us to escape their world and she goes we
need to call the show the great escape
that's cute i got a better one godfather
four
[Laughter]
now was there any attempt and i'm sure
your mom probably
cockblocked this but was there any
attempt for from the old the old boys
out there to try to get you in
no i don't think i mean like i mean i'm
sure if they watch my clips
i'd be like there's no chance with this
guy we've been hearing stuff about you
knocking up as a third grader yeah yeah
we could use you in this we could use a
young guy with you yeah we need a rudy
[Laughter]
no i mean i i don't think so i mean i i
think it was so long ago and like um i
you know i
uh some of them we are friends like on
social media and stuff and like you know
wait what you know like younger family
members and like they have families like
they seem you know what i mean like the
point of the show is like not inc the
point of the show is honestly to show
him in a light of like you think you
know these people but like they are like
multifaceted like as we all are but like
like my dad because like for me i was
when i learned that about like the trunk
and the murder and like this and that i
was like i was ashamed of it you know
really yeah i mean like that's your
father you know what i mean it's not
entertainment it's your dad so it's very
different and then you you know
obviously like you were saying like
these movies like they hold so much for
us in terms of like entertainment value
so people immediately would be like
that's so cool send me the bull this or
that and i would like it was hard
because i was like this is my dad i feel
very differently about this because it's
so personal to me yeah so the show to me
is to like find a way to love my dad
so by the end of it it's like kind of an
examination of like what is a good
person and what is a bad person and
being like he's all these things but i
choose to love him for these other
things even despite you know all this
other stuff wow and like that's in all
of us you know yeah um
you know a good person i put [ __ ] in
perspective because i'm ashamed of my
dad for he wears socks with sandals
upsets me
black socks
but everybody's different if this was e
that would be more of a crime
yeah and that's uh that's it's so
interesting i mean you did a great job
on uh this american life yeah you did an
episode about yeah your uh your grandma
yes that was about my grandma finding uh
love in the nursing home you know like
this blind black guy one leg that you
meant and like my grandma was someone
who swore completely off love
uh my grandfather lived in the living
room my whole childhood wow she banished
him to the living room
so there was like a lot there you
thought he was the tenant i thought he
was a tenant my whole family called him
the tenant no yeah they joked around and
they were like that's a tenant and when
you're a kid you just take everything
your family says is face value yeah so i
was like sure the tenant
and then like you know when you have a
friend come over for the first time
that's when you're like things might be
[ __ ] up around here so my friend john
he's looking around the room and he gets
to this like there's a guy in the living
room no shirt on sweatpants eating a
waffle and he's like who's that guy
and i was like that's the tenant
and he was like what's a tenant and i
was like i don't really know what that
is i asked my mom about it that night
she was like that's not the tenant
that's your grandfather wow and she they
just didn't think that they had to like
disclose that information but for my mom
she was like i was hoping you'd never
ask cause i didn't want you to know
that's what could happen in a marriage
so he cheated on my grandmother in the
60s she never forgave him he wouldn't
leave the house that it was in his name
she wouldn't spend money on a divorce so
she just banished him to the living room
marked all the food in the fridge not
for john except for the waffles and that
was it that's incredible yeah there were
never good times between them ever again
no no no they were yeah well this is the
other thing with him so he died and he
didn't just cheat on her he had a whole
other family
in the bronx so i i think i have like
puerto rican cousins
so so and this was the i just think it's
so funny on his deathbed and my mom
found this out on his death bed in the
hospital she went to go see him and
there was this just like puerto rican
woman on his bed and my mom goes are you
his nurse
and she goes i'm his wife oh
and she goes who are you and she my mom
goes i'm his daughter oh [ __ ] my
grandfather the whole time went i don't
know who she is
wow just played complete ignorance and
then the funeral director walked in like
you know jimmy waffles
[Laughter]
he's like i don't know that guy
yeah no crazy he died insane my
grandmother opened a coors light
just drank it smiled and said where do
you want to celebrate
yeah old school yeah yeah yeah damn old
school
tough tough tough as nails
[Laughter]
yeah
so uh so your grandma met a guy in the
nursing home who was much younger yes it
was a quarter her age so i believe when
she
she met him she was 90 and he was 62. oh
okay and uh yeah and my grandmother too
i mean like she's an italian woman from
jersey like you know her politics are
racist
um and
met him
first honestly i think like the first
black guy she ever like talked to right
and was like oh i was wrong about
everything and then like i mean
retroactive geriatric uh bronx tale
right here yeah yeah man retroactively
claimed she voted for obama
i was like you're a registered
republican it's like not even possible
what's that 32 year age gap there that
doesn't fly that's a lot different when
you're 90. yeah yeah yeah
when you're 40.
either way it's gross yeah
that's true that's so funny all these
like texios are pointing to that story
and they're like it's fine when they do
it though
so that's crazy and and they just they
got married they uh no the problem was
they were going to get married but it
would mess up their medicaid stuff
so we couldn't have them married because
it would mess up like the paperwork to
keep her in the nursing home because it
was so expensive
and she's not an honest woman yeah
yeah yeah
we don't you know we were all ashamed of
her as a sinner um
but so what happened to
so we couldn't do it because the
paperwork but then he was like well i
you know
frank her you know then fiance at the
time was like i want to get married but
he wasn't his own legal guardian his
brother was his brother met my
grandmother and went you can't marry
this woman which i always think is like
so funny that it's like she's 90 years
old and he's like you could do better
one leg
he's blind and he was like not her
damn which i respected though i mean my
grandma was a pill i love her
there's so much here is this stuff gonna
be in this will be in the womb yeah so
this stuff is in the one-man show and
that's what i mean it's like a lot of
these like bridge stories that are like
piggybacking off one another and like i
that's been a hard part too because like
i can't really pull elements because
it's it's so long and it's pretty
self-contained to like pull elements of
this to doing like a club set it like
doesn't make a lot of sense it's a lot
to throw at an audience it's too much
and i get that yeah but that does suck
yeah so i have to do it in its entire
like that's the only way i can work on
is like doing it well new york comedy
you're following like bam
just people like playing the hits and
then it's like very hard to find out
to like figure out a story yes it is
a story with such depth and totally
characters yeah i'll be at a bar and
people are like do you do that on stage
i'll be telling some crazy story and i'm
like no no they're like why not i'm like
it bombs
people hate it they're bored
you're on the road enough that you could
figure that stuff out i think probably i
think it's just tough to to figure it
out in the city that's when it's like
yes yeah so true they're short spots and
the rhythm of everybody's sets are short
because the spots are short and like i
mean new york is like man it's an
impatient town oh yeah you know so like
the audience are so the audiences are so
savvy for comedy right away and also
like they know the pace of it yeah if
you don't have a joke every second like
you're toast oh it's not just it's not
just the jokes it's like it's ordering a
sandwich yeah yeah
if you're beating around the bush the
guy's like get to it yeah
even yeah even walking you ever have a
guy stop to like read a plaque you're
like what the [ __ ] man go back to iowa
yeah the guy's like i grew up in the
brock over brooklyn
[Laughter]
well that's the thing everybody here is
mad at whoever they see because that's
potential space they no longer have yeah
you know so it's like everybody they see
that you're like you're what's keeping
me from shopping at trader joe's on a
saturday if you weren't here i could do
that dude so i'm furious at you i had
this today and i'm not trying to sound
like a chew cheer but yeah i'm walking
to the train to come here
and
you know i'm kind of hustling i'm kind
of hustling and a homeless guy goes can
i get some change and i go ah [ __ ] it
and i pull i go for the change and i
pull it out my keys come out the keys
hit the ground i drop the change so now
me and the hobo are doing the whole
change dance i'm like trying to help
them pick it up i go all right you're on
your own i leave i see the train go by
and i'm like if i hadn't helped that
hobo i would have caught that train and
so i'm done with hobos no more money for
you
but that's how this city is it warps
it warps whatever humanity you had just
because like
every everything's laid everything oh
man mark jumps back over the turn stuff
says [ __ ] wailing on the guy
that's what you get
he misses another train he's like [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of him
people watching are like oh marital
dispute everyone's like so progressive
[Laughter]
yeah dude i mean this i can't wait to
see this show i think it's going to be
amazing and you have an album of
different stuff coming out yeah and a
special yes when's the specials out next
week right i have a standout special
that's out may 26th uh on my youtube
page so whoever's listening to this for
the love of god subscribe to my youtube
channel we love aunt because i got
nobody he's he's great
you know we are we're joke snobs we love
him
dream occupation another great album
yeah half hour specials you've seen him
on uh colbert follow his instagram
you'll see the clips and everything yeah
you really got to get on it
twitter's great too a lot of jokes yeah
the clips are great yeah that's you guys
man out of the pandemic i just saw that
you you guys have you guys have fans now
and it was a lot in fact due to like the
clips i mean i fought it for years
because i was like
this is anti-con whatever i thought
whatever in my precious head that i
thought but now i see it as like that's
kind of the way so it's another job
it's another job but it's worth it after
i saw sort of what you guys have with it
so it's a lot due to you guys yeah i
don't want to try to and we we write a
lot of jokes all three of us so like we
have a backlog yeah so now we can have
we have [ __ ] to post where i don't know
if everyone has that backlog yeah so
yeah
it's made for us i mean it really is but
it is a [ __ ] to do it do you have any
do you have any peeves i know it's weird
to go from all this heavy stuff to just
like light pee
it's maybe a way to know your father
[Laughter]
no yeah no i i thought of something i'm
just trying to uh rem uh remember it now
um i had something to do with like
tech people or like corporations uh
can do do you mind you don't mind if i
look at my phone no no look at the phone
you got anything well i just want to
relate because i have a [ __ ] up
childhood and people always go you got
to talk about it but i maybe a
one-person show or whatever you're
calling it is the the that might be yeah
you might that might be great for you i
got a transvestite nanny growing up like
a big black guy and a wig a
cross-dressing nanny yeah way ahead of
your time yes i mean that's why in new
orleans in the 90s and the the house
with the robberies and the dilapidated
so i'm like this has given me this is
inspiring to me yeah i mean also too
like it is good i mean like in general
to be like because you know you know
your voice as you do comedy so you know
like not to say you become or whatever
but like you know how you're gonna do
stuff you know what i mean yeah like so
to do something that's so out of the
realm of what you normally do it's
possible that you actually grow as a
stand-up from it i don't know that i'm
seeing any of that growth just yet but
i'm like optimistic
yeah it's like bill burt says if you
can't go left go left you know learn it
right figure it out yeah great tony v
quote
uh years ago
i think it might have been billboard i
don't know tony v is like this boston
legend guy killer comic older guy and uh
bill burgo's uh tony you know he's like
a year in he's like you know i love
doing comedy i love writing jokes but i
hate this network [ __ ] i hate the the
glad handing and all that i don't know
how to do that [ __ ] and tony just goes
get good at it
and that was it and he's like yeah yeah
you can't just like i don't like this so
i'm not doing it it's like no do it
blunt is right i remember i saw a comic
complaining to a tell once about like
not
it's like oh it's not working for me and
until just goes get funnier
yeah not in a way like you're not right
it was a comic he likes a lot but a
teller just being like what else is
there to do yeah that's that's getting
blunter or realer than that yeah i don't
know i don't mind that at all because
it's like worse comes to worse you just
get great at this thing you know what i
mean instead of blaming a bunch of stuff
oh my god worst case scenario you don't
get all the things you want but you
became great at this thing yes so fine
that's definitely not the worst case
scenario
but you know what i mean like dead in a
gutter sure yeah yeah like but you
understand i know what you mean yeah
yeah
yeah how much how much of that facebook
[ __ ] do you see of like this guy and
that guy and you're like yeah but you
still suck at the end of the day even if
we gave everything to you you would
still bomb right so get better and i
think that's better too as just like a
mindset as a comic you know what i mean
like yeah i don't know how you guys are
but like i work better when i
have like a healthy chip on my shoulder
or i position myself as like the
underdog yeah do you know what i mean
sure so if i can say to myself oh i just
need to get funnier not in a desperate
way but just in a way that's like oh
that'll make me work harder like that's
always better oh yeah oh yeah i know a
comic he's pretty funny he's pretty good
we all know him but every show he gets
off stage and goes the crowd's a little
whatever the crowd is not great they're
a little tight they're a little weird
and then other people will kill and
you're like you got to start
internalizing this you got to stop just
every time you're going to blame the
crowd if they're not amazing yeah come
on yeah and it's like even if that's
real
there is that i'm not saying that's not
bad totally but every time but even if
that's real it's like oh man it's like
better if you go oh i'll be better than
they are bad exactly
dude or woman who's scared of success
who does that say it again that's
someone who's scared of success oh yeah
yeah i think because you can't you can't
just be like they're good right you have
to you're blaming them which means i
think you're you're
you're not dealing with other [ __ ]
interesting when you're blaming the
audience yeah well he's not successful
so
he's doing great
yeah it's like we all do it in the heat
of the moment because it's like a
visceral reaction but it's like yeah
like that's so much better if you go oh
yeah i'll i'll it doesn't matter who who
they are or what they are i'll figure
something out to get something out of
them totally totally you know it's
easier said than done obviously yeah it
is it hurts but you got to do it but man
my pet peeve no did you find it
yeah okay it just says coffee snaps i
know what this is coffee stops coming up
i get so intimidated because i was like
but these like coffee shops i think what
it is is like
they have so much coffee stuff around
them that i'm like oh they know so much
about coffee so whatever i order they're
judging my order and they make me feel
stupid but i think this is probably more
just my own projection but i think
everything i say like if i'm like i'll
take a red either like you would
yeah
just snobs in general yeah and i think
it's because they have they have so like
you know they and it could all be for
show those like chemex things like all
the like the [ __ ] that they have but
like but i go these are experts and i
feel like such a novice and it's just a
drink
it's so dumb
i feel the same way you know what bugs
me more than that is like them thinking
that i think i know what i'm talking
about sure i can tell i can't so my
opener's always like i don't know [ __ ]
right
or whatever you reckon like same with
wine i'm like i don't know [ __ ] yeah yes
but whatever you think you know although
i will take chances on that
we did a few episodes with the natural
wine and it's funky and it's weird great
yeah it's fun to get drunk on i like
that natural [ __ ] yeah are you guys
developing more of a palette just i
wouldn't say that
i didn't
i didn't mean to give you any uh
indication that we're not trash
no i mean i like
sam yay
[Laughter]
could be a shirt episode that's my dj
name but
no i do like
getting drunk on wine is kind of fun
it's a different drunk right right i
mean yeah whiskey is like a more intense
yeah tequila's a little more like uh but
wine you're just silly loose you're
loose and silly and you might slip it's
funny it's weird i'll dance i'll [ __ ]
yeah the floor seems wet yeah yeah it's
a good time yeah you're loosey-goosey
totally man i like how you're like did
you guys get your palate better i'm like
we're drinking rum and cokes
it's gonna be a more
but yeah i think there's some stuff i
guess i think rum and coke was drunk
like a lot of adults drank rum and cokes
around me yeah so i always associate
that with like that's an adult drink
even though it's like you know it's for
real estate agents who aren't doing well
yeah
whatever but in my head i'll never stop
that like little kid brain of like this
is what the sophisticated adults drink a
rum and coke i can't take rum seriously
to me rum is like beachy pina colada but
yeah i i just never touch rum really
it's not it's not for me although i
think hemingway drip was a big rum guy i
think he was a big everything guy but he
was also a he was like on the beach guy
he was like dressed
in jamaica cuba he was like a linen guy
you know yes he you know he could wear
one of those like straw hats and like
you kind of wouldn't question it you
know those guys are like anybody else i
would think is a douche but for you i
feel like you're important i feel like
good rum though is the [ __ ] i feel like
if you have really good ramen yeah on
the rocks oh and i just don't know
enough about it yeah i would never do
that on the rock yeah the romance of rum
i like the fact that it's like a pirate
drink yeah you know what i mean i love
that and i can fool myself for one sip
you know with going like this is what
you drink on a wooden boat but after two
sips i'm like i hate this yeah yeah yeah
then you break it down you're like
what's worse than being drunk at sea
it's true oh yeah nauseous you feel like
[ __ ]
you're gonna deal with pirates yeah
maybe that's why they're so angry yeah
yeah maybe you could trace it back to
the rum and it's like maybe if you
eliminate the rum you wouldn't swindle
so much you get a real drop on land
that's the bar fight of the sea is
you're just getting hijacked yes that
sucks absolutely good point i can't that
dismount and mounting onto a ship had to
be such an uncomfortable part of the
robbery do you know what i mean none of
it's swift no no it's clunky they make
it look sweet with the swinging off the
whatever you land on it you got the
sword in your mouth you know or you go
down the curtain you know with the sword
or the sail that's a fun one i [ __ ] it
up so hard i'd be bleeding from my lips
yeah this guy sucks yeah in reality you
have like one leg over the ship it's
like they're helping you on
very it's like lumbered you know why
they do the eye patch why it's not that
i'm missing it's depth perception
because when you sail you gotta like
know the bow and the starboard and all
this [ __ ] so they
it helps them ah it's they actually have
a working eye it's just something with
nautical [ __ ] i'll tell you what it
doesn't help with though if someone
tries to punch you from the right
[Laughter]
man
you are sacrificing that
you're gonna get a lot of right hooks
[Laughter]
oh sorry oh no go ahead well the plank i
never got either because sure it's like
this six foot
wooden beam that they push you out on
you know this guy's silly cuffed or
whatever and they go ah then you jump
like you could just push them over like
why do we need the flank aspect i don't
know i guess it's anticipation that's
their entertainment i guess so you know
that's the life of a pirate what they
find entertaining is killing a man right
i mean it's like write a story you have
a journal
instead they're like you know we find
fun if we eliminate mark in the open
seat
well they also said man you get so crazy
out there it's sun yeah
rum i know exactly where you're headed
manatee yeah mermaid yep that's how
horny they were they were making these
amenities looking pretty good yeah how
nuts is that yeah that's beyond prison
gay yes
yeah for sure manatee sexual
that's a whole other thing of isolation
yeah
i mean animal sex is definitely worse
than
[Music]
look up maybe maybe the eye patch was
the sunlight you go to the bottom deck
and it's dark it was something with with
eye adjustment give that a goog
no that makes i don't want to get that
wrong i have a bunch of pirates come at
me
well sure today's pirates yeah very less
festive yes yes a lot of cargo less
communal singing oh below deck okay
there you go yeah less yo-ho-ho
less parrots for sure
yeah the poor parrot that got wrangled
in with these criminals i don't know he
didn't want this life no yeah you're a
colorful bird yeah
why not get a street pigeon those things
already they look like the criminals of
the bird world that's true
uh great uh one time
i think i've said this on the public uh
will so vince was like annoying dave
attel like from the crowd like trying to
get some attention you know will's this
short skinny black guy with a big beard
and uh davidson goes easy captain
phillips
gets me every time here it is man he's
so fast and his voice is so silly you
don't have a chance to be hurt do you
know what i mean no chance dude dave
chappelle he called out
sorry
big difference big difference i tell
once he said uh he called hummus uh
peanut terrorist pizza
all this pirate talks getting me a
little oh yeah yeah and by the way this
is i know what time i was this is
whiskey not roman oh [ __ ] we got rum
last week as a gift on a patreon but uh
oh yeah whiskey elijah craig is whiskey
yeah good good whiskey do you guys have
your bottle of booze coming out yet or
is that something
i mean this is a pre okay this is a pre
uh we're backlogging episodes here this
is going away but i mean
hopefully it's out by now yeah that's
the dream we'll do maybe we'll do like a
drama before an episode or something if
it comes out but pretty cool i'm [ __ ]
pumped i can't wait for that can't wait
i just love the idea of having our own
booze we're in the spirits game dude
yeah yeah you guys are in the spirits
game are you gonna do it'd be fun if you
did like a mock commercial kind of oh
yeah yeah
yeah it's like
yeah yeah yes i like that can't be too
silly people need to know we actually
have a whiskey
if we go too soon they're gonna be like
well this is a joke right you get simon
rex in there people aren't gonna know
that's not bad do it dude yeah that
would be fun man like those old school
like d serrano like like shiva's regal
like yeah you know when like alcohol
commercials like blurred the lines of
like cologne commercials where you're
like this is like an art film
it's so dramatic i got an idea we go
real dramatic real artsy and then we
pull back and we're driving
we're drinking and driving great that's
good all right that's really funny dude
but you can't put that on tv and then
it's just uh the car just jumps off a
[ __ ] bridge
and explodes we show that tesla footage
you know with that big jump that he did
hell yeah
plug where you're gonna be oh um
man yeah thanks for bringing up dates ah
man
oh i'll be at moon tower that's pretty
good oh i'll see if this is this is uh
this is coming up in may i mean hey
honestly the thing i really want to plug
is the may 26th my special will be
dropping on my youtube page called brain
noise a stand-up special please follow
uh subscribe to me on youtube and follow
me on instagram and at uh comedian
anthony devito elliott tick-tock as well
thank you
are you opening for ari at the casey
improv and i'm opening ferrari at the uh
kansas city improv club may 21st and
22nd
square theater
oh yeah and i'm doing the one-man show
in dc at the comedy life on june 8th man
i always try to sell tickets now in the
moment i get flustered and then uh you
know uh yeah i get um
all right boy you're gonna blow arie off
the stage huh
just kidding ahri
he's getting old uh we got albany uh
nashville and i've already been in
nashville toronto
rhode island special taping in chicago
tampa cleveland houston west palm
buffalo san jose all over that [ __ ]
samwell.com
hell yeah san jose that's a big room
when am i in chicago am i am i catching
up on your date there at all okay just
checking i'm uh this weekend i'm at
bricktown comedy club in oklahoma city
good room then i'm uh san jose i think
canceled sorry stand up live in
huntsville alabama pantages theater in
minneapolis chicago june 17th all right
that gives us a little buffer
and then one week one week
i'm doing the birch shows uh look up
fully loaded fest.com i believe it is
and then uh irvine improv we need you to
come out that's a big room as well red
bank new jersey devito's home state oh
yeah man houston improv that's a big
room laugh out loud in san antonio
markdom and comedy.com check out the
show the the website the patreon
get on the page
we might be drunk pod merch we might be
drunk pod.com shout out to gotham
studios matt you're you're saving us
every week uh and to uh of course uh you
know we might be drunk pod at gmail.com
email us rex uh drinks jokes peeves
whatever you want so whatever you got
yeah and uh yeah check out anthony's one
of the one of the new york greats
i'm going to that one man oh for sure
yeah man yeah that'd be awesome we
should come but for sure can't wait to
see it what's the
story uh i'll be doing in dc at the
comedy loft oh i'm doing a qed in
question oh oh that one i forgot april
29th
come to qed get him date i'll be there
qed yeah
that's gonna be great
we love you we love you tony the third
grader definitely go
definitely go see a show he's a great
comic and it's gonna be a great show
yeah hell yeah that that sounds like a
movie if you ask me yeah we'll see man
we just had judd apatow on so if judd is
judd if you're listening oh judd that
coward
[Laughter]
all right thank you guys thank you
sunday's the day for my next bender a
bit of peeve you know the future's close
i've had a little too much burping and
norman's talking [ __ ] about the [ __ ]
[Music]
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new orleans
this woman doesn't look like i remember
her and i get down in the same way
we might
be
true
[Music]